hey I'm so Vichy lazy and today we are
behind the scenes with Lennon Stella on
the set of her new music video
you know that husband or crash tell me
why we're in this really cool old house
and it's honestly just outside this
house is like my dream it's like kind of
eerie and different weird things that
are happening throughout it's a really
cool vibe and feeling to the video that
I'm like as we're shooting him just like
this is like my dreams coming to life
now Maddie Ziegler was here today she is
actually like my sister's best friends
like they're so tight and I just I'm
just literally adore her so much as a
human and she's like a freak talent and
and she's so beautiful so I just thought
like yeah just have her in have her in
and just be another face she's such a it
she's such a cool vibe to have little
Easter eggs for ya and and I saw your
sisters here today - oh my gosh she
could not be more supportive it's so
nice like having her so involved in
everything like literally she's the
go-to for me the person I send like the
second I got the treatment she was the
first person I send it to like on it say
she's so involved in it it's just nice
to have her here now the song itself is
pretty strongly worded to say that ease
[Music]
[Applause]
tell me about what or who inspired it
honestly this is one of the only song or
actually only song I've ever written
that wasn't like a true story that
something actually happened to me it was
just a concept but yeah it's like this
guy calling a girl a [ __ ] and almost in
a joking way and instead of kind of
taking it she just stands up for
something she's like you're being a
little bit now I understand you are
working towards a full-length we've got
the EP out now full length coming at
some point yeah I'm just I'm writing a
bunch right now I feel like after
putting an EP out I got like a three
like boost of energy and like filled of
like inspiration just because I written
for so long and nothing was you know
being put out and so after everything
got put out I was just like and just a
response and like the love and
everything just like re-inspired me and
I think that now I'm just taking that
inspiration and just writing a bunch and
like kind of I feel a little bit more
like I'm able to like just expand and
like create a little bit more I don't
know why I just feel a little bit freer
and then there's there's a cool like
couple collaborations I can't really say
much about but those that's what we want
to know me to look forward to absolutely
and I think I think it's gonna be super
super exciting can you give us any hints
on the club I I honestly I'm so scared
of what would happen if I actually did
give a hint on the class you're gonna
not give a hit on the club but it is it
is one that I think people probably have
already thought about it like I think
people can see it already happening so
it's not like completely crazy random
it's like I think people are probably
already assuming that's gonna happen
alright
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you have some serious stands across both
the country world and the pop world
which is so amazing is that something
that you have to be conscious of it all
with your Nashville background when
you're creating honestly yeah I mean to
a certain extent I feel like I
definitely want to keep everybody on
board and I don't want it to be like
it's such a big dramatic shift of like
I'm not country and more people kind of
you know that's they viewed Nashville as
a country show and I think that that's
where that sat in that world and now
going into like the pop world I
definitely want it to be a smooth
transition it's definitely something I
think about and not you know making this
like complete shift and you know making
everybody be like what happened
everybody Conrad so I'm definitely like
keeping keeping that in mind for sure
thank you for having us you so much for
coming
[Music]